[Music]  both of your brothers are actors and you  guys like to mess with each other and  you like for example your brother Chris  you got into it with him recently on  Instagram Yeah right we had a little  Instagram thing and I'd started with you  you posted a picture of your dog chewing  up a Thor action figure and really  disfiguring him I guess he responded he  drew all over your magazine cover on  men's health and disfigured it okay a  little bit and then you followed you  fired back insulted him by drawing all  over his Vanity Fair cover my question  is why is red hair and insult  [Applause]  I don't quite get why that's the meanest  thing you can find he was like you win  red hair there's no coming back from  that curly wildness of macaques  it wasn't the cover the color you find  you travel the colors great I love red  yeah red wonderful hair color the house  my cry will you hug me yeah that's the  worst acting job  you